We've just been giving such killer vocals all night.
I'm worried that we're going to
melt the audience's faces off.
♪♪
Merry Christmas, everybody.
I feel very overdressed, mate.
♪♪
Oh, my God, one of my best friends
has got a Christmas special.
Haha.
♪♪
Hey, guys, Hannah Waddingham calling.
Hannah Waddingham :
I am here at the glorious London Coliseum
to record my Christmas special.
Hannah Waddingham, home for Christmas on Apple TV+.
Announcer:
Miss Waddingham to stage, please.
♪Choir singing carols right outside my door.♪
♪All these things and more, baby♪
♪All these things and more, my baby♪
♪That's what Christmas means to me, my love♪
Hannah Waddingham :
The London Coliseum has been my home
since I was eight years old.
Hannah Waddingham :
My mum started in the chorus here.
Hannah Waddingham:
It has always held such a place in my heart, and now I'm fronting my own show here.
What I would have given to do this show in a pair of Birkenstocks.
Man:
Oh, Hannah, Hannah, Hannah
Hahah!
Look!
♪♪
Both:
Hey!
♪♪
I was so excited to get the most glorious people involved.
It's amazing to be part of this family.
James Lance:
It's so cool, and Christmas is all about family, right?
Wadders, we're all here because we love you, and we think you're amazing.
Phil Dunster:
A lot of Christmas elves running around just sprinkling their Christmas magic.
It's quite mad.
There's a lot going on.
Nick Mohammed:
Lots of kind of choreography and flying rehearsals.
This is a lifelong dream for her, and I couldn't be more proud of this woman.
Juno Temple:
And I can't believe she asked me to be a part of it.
Hahah.
I'm your Christmas miracle!
Both:
Ah!
Shh!
Hannah Waddingham :
I have a beautiful mixture of friends.
The fabulous lounge swingers.
Please welcome the London Gay Men's Chorus.
♪ You look gorgeous tonight ♪
And global stars,
Mr. Leslie Odom, Jr.
(Crowd Cheering)
Hannah, you are making everybody proud today, and so happy, so full of joy.
Thank you for the special.
Please welcome Luke Evans.
Hannah, my love, I've known you for a very long time, and it's just a joy to be on a stage with you tonight.
Merry Christmas!
Sam Ryder!
You embody such a spirit of the craft. It's a total honor, my friend.
Hello.
Girl:
Just seeing all these different worlds collide, you know, people in the audience, the people on stage,
Hannah Waddingham:
it's the very best of times, with the very best people.
-We're going to support each other for the rest of our lives
-You're so right, we are.
-We are.
-And this is a big deal!
It is.
♪♪
Thank you for letting us all be a part of it.
Nick Mohammed:
It's a dream come true.
♪♪
Hannah, congratulations on achieving your dream.
It was lovely.
Hannah Waddingham.
Kola Bokinni:
Hannah, we love you.
You're going to smash it as usual.
Christmas.
Thanks for having us.
I'm feeling quite Christmassy. Are you?
This whole experience has been the greatest pinch me moment.
It was an utter, utter pipe dream.
Mwah!
Thank you from my sparkly heart.
(Crowd Cheering)
♪♪